we
can ask briefly what were those early
days of arpanet
and the internet like what was uh
what i mean did you uh again sorry for
the silly question
but could you have possibly imagined
that uh the the internet would look like
what it is today
you know some of it is remarkably
unchanged
so like one of the things that i noticed
really early on
um at you know when i was at at
carnegie mellon was that a lot of
social life became centered around the
arpanet
so things like you know between email
and
text messaging because
you know text messaging was a part of
the arpanet really early
on there were no cell phones but you
know you're
sitting at a terminal and you're typing
stuff and
essentially email or like what what well
just like
like a one-line message right so so so
oh cool so like chat like chat yeah
right so it's like like sending a
one-line message to somebody
right and and and so
pretty much everything from
you know arranging lunch to
going out on dates you know it was all
like
driven by social media
right in the in the in the 80s
easier than phone calls yeah you know
and
my life had gotten to where you know
i was you know living on social media
you know from like the
early mid 80s um
and and so when when it sort of
transformed into the internet
and social media explodes i was kind of
like
what's the big deal it's just a scale
thing it's it's right the the the scale
thing is just
astonishing yeah um but the fundamentals
um in some ways the fundamentals of have
hardly changed and you know the
the technologies behind the the
networking have changed significantly
the
you know the the the watershed moment of
you know going from the arpanet to the
internet
um and then people starting to just
scale and scale and scale i mean the
the the the scaling that happened in the
early 90s
and the way that
so many vested interests fought the
internet
oh who oh interesting what was the oh
because you can't really control the
internet
yeah about the internet so so so
fundamentally
the you know the cable tv companies and
broadcasters
and phone companies
you know at the deepest fibers of their
being
they hated the internet but
it was often kind of a funny thing
because um
you know so so so think of a cable
company
right most of the employees of the cable
their job is getting
tv shows movies whatever
out to their customers they view their
business
as serving their customers
um but as you climb up the hierarchy
in the in the cable companies
that view shifts because
um really
the business of the cable companies
that had always been selling eyeballs to
advertisers
right um
and you know that view of of like a
cable company
didn't really dawn on most people who
worked at the cable companies
but you know we you know i had various
dust-ups with
various cable companies where you could
see you know in the stratified layers of
the corporation that
that this this this this this view of
you know the reason that you have you
know
cable tv is to capture eyeballs
you know there they didn't see it that
way well so so the people who
the most the people who worked at the
phone company
are at the cable companies their view
was
that their their job was getting
delightful content out to their
customers
and their customers would pay for them
would pay for that
higher up they viewed this as as a way
of attracting eyeballs
to them and and then
what they were really doing was selling
the eyeballs that were glued to their
content
to the advertisements to the advertisers
yeah
and so the internet was a competition in
that sense right
and and and and they were right well
yeah um i mean there was one proposal
that we
sent the the we one detailed
proposal that that we um
wrote up you know back at that sun in
the in the early 90s that was
essentially like
look anybody you know with it with
internet technologies
anybody can become provider
of of content so you know
you could be distributing home movies to
your parents
or your cousins or your who are anywhere
else right so
anybody can become a publisher wow you
were thinking about that already yeah
yeah that yeah was was
that that was like in the in the early
90s yeah
and we thought this would be great
you could you know and the kind of
content we were thinking about at the
time was
like you know home movies kids essays
um you know stuff from
like grocery stores or you know you know
that
or or a restaurant that they could
actually
like start sending information about
out and um
that's brilliant and and the the the the
reaction of the cable companies was
like no
because because then
we're out of business what is it about
companies that
because they could have just they could
have been ahead of that wave
they could have listened to that and
they could have they didn't see a path
to revenue
you know there's there's somewhere in
there there's a lesson for like
big companies right like to to listen
to to try to anticipate the the renegade
the out there out of the box
people like yourself in the early days
writing proposals about
what this could possibly be well and
that you know that you know it wasn't
you know if you're in a in a position
where you're making
truckloads of money off of a particular
business model
um you know the
the the the the whole um
thought of like you know leaping the
chasm
right you know you know you can see oh
new models
that are more effective are emerging
right so like digital cameras versus
film cameras um
you know i mean why take the leap why
take the leap because you're making
so much money off of film
and um
you know in my past at sun one of our
big customers was kodak
and i ended up interacting with folks
from kodak quite a lot
and they actually had a big um
digital camera research and you know
digital imaging business
or b development group
and they knew
that that you know you you know you just
look at the
at the trend lines and you look at um
you know the emerging quality of
of of these you know digital cameras
and you know you can just plot it on the
graph
you know and it's like you know sure
film is better today
but you know
digital is is is is improving like this
the lines are going to cross and
and you know the point at which the
lines cross is going to be a
collapse in their business and
they could see that right they
absolutely knew that the problem is that
you know
up to the point where they hit the wall
they were making truckloads of money
yeah
right and when they did the math
um it never started to make sense for
them to
kind of lead the charge and
part of the issues for a lot of
companies for this kind of stuff
is that um you know if you're going to
leap over a chasm like that like like
with
kodak going from from film to digital
that's a transition that's going to take
a while
right we had we had fights like this
with people over like smart carts
the smart cards fights were just
ludicrous
you